물가의 공포가 현실화되는 순간일까요? 오늘도 나스닥이 1.16% 하락을 하고 있습니다. 어떤 부분에서 쟁점이 되는지를 좀 볼 거고요. 기술주 위주로 되어 있는 나스닥 외에 특별히 더 하락을 하고 있는 건 바로 러셀 2000 지수인데요. 러셀 2000 지수는
중소형주로 구성이 되어 있어요. 러셀 2000 지수가 오늘 2.3% 빠지고 있는데 나스닥보다 러셀이 더 빠진다는 것은 물가에 대한 공포가 있다고 보셔도 될 것 같습니다.
왜냐하면 중소형주가 돈을 더 빌리기가 어렵기 때문에 금리 인상에 더 취약하거든요. 그래서 그런 공포감이 러셀 2000 지수의 하락에서 나타났다 이렇게 볼 수가 있겠고요.
자 오늘의 증시를 짧게 요약을 해보자면 이 한 장으로 요약을 할 수가 있을 것 같습니다.
호르무즈 봉쇄가 계속 장기화되는 그런 분위기로 가고 있고 유가가 또 104불, WTI가 104달러 이렇게 뚫다 보니까 또다시 인플레이션 우려가 재점화가 됐고요.
인플레이션이 높아지는 게 점점 확실해지다 보니까 모든 글로벌 시장에서 채권에 대한 매도세가 강해졌습니다.
채권이 매도가 되면 채권의 금리는 올라가겠죠. 채권의 금리가 올라가는 모습이 나타나면서 채권의 금리가 올라가면 결국에 기업들 입장에서는 좋을 게 없죠.
금리가 올라가면 돈 빌리기도 어려워지는 거고 주식이라는 것 자체가 미래의 현금 흐름이기 때문에 그 할인율이 커진다라는 것 자체가 주가에는 나쁜 영향을 주기 때문에 주가가 동반 하락하는 2022년이 생각나는 그런 움직임을 가진 하루였다 이렇게 볼 수가 있겠습니다.
그래서 10년물 미국 국채 수익률이 장 초반에 4.54%를 돌파했는데 이게 작년 5월 이후에 1년 만에 최고치를 달성을 한 거예요.
지금 시장에서 가장 주목하는 건 바로 금리라고 보시면 됩니다.
물가가 장기간 높아질 거다라는 걱정이 있기 때문에 시장에서는 고정된 돈을 주는 채권을 파는 그런 매도세가 강한 거라고 보시면 되고요.
브랜트유 같은 경우는 109달러가 또 돌파를 했습니다. 그래서 인플레이션 우려가 재점화되고 있다 이렇게 볼 수가 있겠고요.
어쨌든 또 이란과 관련된 갈등 또 단기 종전에 대한 기대가 계속 꺾이면서 추가 상승하고 있다고 보시면 되는데
기본적으로는 좀 이런 거였죠. 미중 정상회담이 오늘 끝났잖아요. 그런데 이제 미중 정상회담에서 양측 모두 전쟁 종식을 원한다라고 했지만
사실은 미국과 중국이 정상회담을 하면서 그 어떤 것도 달라진 게 없어요. 뭔가 이란 전쟁에 대한 해결책을 시장에선 기대했는데 그런 게 없었습니다.
시장은 사실상 노딜로 해석을 하는 거죠. 야 아무 일도 없구나. 기대감이 좀 있었는데 누군가 나한테 선물을 줄 줄 알았는데 그 선물을 열어봤더니 빈 껍데기였다 뭐 이런 느낌이죠.
시장에서 기분 나빠하고 있고 그런 기분 나쁨이 오늘 채권 금리 움직임 또 주식의 움직임에서 나오고 있는 거고요.
그런 관점에서 또 금리 전망 자체가 좀 재조정이 되고 있습니다. 그래서 유가의 고공 행진이 어느 정도 장기화될 것이다 이런 베팅들이 조금씩 좀 나오고 있고요.
그래서 올해 금리 인하를 좀 할 수도 있을 거다라는 기대감이 있었는데 그런 기대감이 점점 줄어들고 있다라고 볼 수가 있는 데다가 오늘도 미국 채권뿐만 아니라 글로벌 채권 시장이 전반적으로 안 좋았어요.
영국 채권 같은 경우는 지금 이제 영국의 총리 사무총리가 있는 당이 총선에서 패배하면서 지금 영국의 총리가 바뀐다 이런 얘기가 많은데 새롭게 바뀔 만한 영국의 총리가 좀 더 좌파적인 경향이 있고 쉽게 말해서 좀 돈을 더 풀고 돈을 더 많이 쓰려고 하는 그런 경향이 있기 때문에 영국 정부가 재정 정책을 더 많이 한다 돈을 더 많이 빌린다 돈을 더 많이 빌리면 영국 국채의 금리가 올라갈 수밖에 없겠죠.
영국 채권 다 갖고 싶지 않겠죠.
영국 채권의.
매도 압력이 강해지면서 영국 채권 금리가 급등을 했고요.
일본 국채의 금리도 역시 급등을 했는데 일본 국채 금리가 급등을 한 건 일본의 4월 ppi 생산자 물가 지수가 전년 대비 4.9%나 상승하는 모습을 보였기 때문입니다.
자 일본도 이렇게 물가가 뛰면은 일본 은행이 더 이상 낮은 기준 금리를 고수하기가 어렵겠죠.
일본 중앙은행도 결국에는 금리를 올리려고 할 텐데.
자 일본 중앙은행이 금리를 올리는 건.
채권 금리의 상승만을 얘기하는 게 아니라 결국에 n 캐리 청산이라고 작년 8월에 시장을 불타오르게 했었죠.
그래서 n으로 빌린 돈들이 전세계에 너무 많다 보니까 그 전세계 유동성이 n으로 빌린 돈으로 인해서 만들어진 게 되게 많은데 n화가 강해지면 그렇게 전세계에 뿌려졌던 유동성이 다시 들어오면서 전세계 많은 자산의 매도 압력을 만들거든요.
그런 것에 대한 공포감도 좀 있었고요.
자 오늘 히트맵을 좀 보면 어떤 주식이 오르고 어떤 주식이 떨어졌는지를 보면 대부분 반도체 주식이.
떨어졌다 이렇게 볼 수가 있을 것 같아요.
그래서 지금 시뻘건 애들이 대부분 반도체 주식입니다.
엔비디아 브로드컴 마이크론 amd 인텔 이런 애들이 이제 쫙 떨어졌습니다.
다만 그중에서도 마이크로소프트는 오늘 좀 상승을 하고 있는데요.
왜 상승을 하고 있냐면 마이크로소프트는 억만장자 해지펀드 매니저 얼굴 되게 잘생겼는데 빌 에크먼이라는 사람이 내가 매수를 했다라고 얘기를 하면서 상승을 했어요.
빌 에크먼의 펄싱스케어가 마이크로소프트를 신규 편입했다.
라고 본인이 엑스에서 발표를 했고 또 공시를 할 예정이다 라고도 얘기를 했습니다.
그래서 마이크로소프트가 실적 발표 후에 주가 급락을 했을 때부터 사 모았다 라고 하네요.
그래서 마이크로소프트의 밸류에이션이 약 포드 기준으로 포드 per 기준으로 21배 정도 되는데 시장의 현재 멀티풀과 크게 차이가 없고
마이크로소프트의 역사적인 멀티풀에 비해서는 현저히 낮은 수준이다 라고 얘기를 하면서 빅테크 중에서 가장 소외됐다.
마이크로소프트가 그런 얘기를 합니다. 그러면서 빌 에크먼이 뭐라고 했냐 마이크로소프트의 그런 가치의 오픈 AI의 지분의 가치를 반영해야 되는데
지금 오픈 AI가 상장하면 원트리런 달러 넘을 거고 주요 주주 중에 하나가 마이크로소프트인데 이거를 반영 안 하는 게 말이 되느냐 라는 게 있고
또 하나는 엔터프라이즈 시장에서 가장 가치 있는 프랜차이즈를 두 개나 갖고 있다는 거죠.
그래서 아무래도 애저와 마이크로소프트 365.
두 개가 엔터프라이즈 시장에서 가장 의미 있고 가치 있는 프랜차이즈다 라고 얘기를 하는 것 같아요.
근데 이제 마이크로소프트가 상대적으로 좀 다른 빅테크에 비해서 좀 부진하는 이유가 제가 생각을 하기에는
구글이랑 좀 비교를 하면 구글 같은 경우는 자신만의 언어 모델을 갖고 있는 것도 있고
구글 아마존은 좀 엔트로픽의 힘을 좀 최근에 많이 받았다.
엔트로픽의 덕을 많이 본 회사가 구글과 아마존인데 마이크로소프트는 오픈 AI의 덕을 봤어야 되는데 최근에 오픈 AI가 좀 상대적으로
부진했고 그런 부진함이 최근 좀 마이크로소프트의 안 좋은 주가에 반영이 되지 않았나 라는 생각이 하나가 들고요.
또 하나는 마이크로소프트가 이제 점점 AI 상품을 기존의 자신들이 갖고 있는 마이크로소프트 365에 껴서 팔기를 하려고 하는데 그게 좀 잘 안 되더라고요.
실적 발표를 보니까 AI 기능을 붙여서 기존의 엔터프라이즈 시장에서 마이크로소프트의 제품을 기업용 제품을 팔려고 하는데 그게 좀 잘 안 된다 라는 것들이 보이면서 좀 주가가 상대적으로 좀 부진한 그런 상황입니다.
마이크로소프트 같은 경우는 단타치는 스타일은 아니고 한번 보유하면 좀 오래 가져가고 또 꽤 집중 투자도 하는 스타일이에요.
그래서 빌크먼의 움직임 좀 의미가 있을 수 있겠다 이런 말씀을 좀 드리고 싶습니다.
자 그 외에도 아까도 말씀드리겠지만 마이크론도 5% 하락 중이고 또 디렘 ETF라고 있죠.
요즘에 가장 핫한 ETF 메모리와 저장장치 관련된 것들을 전부 다 갖고 있는 ETF인 디렘 ETF가 5%나 하락 중인데 최근에 일본 증식 끝나고 랜드만 만드는 회사인 키오시아의 실적이 매우 잘 나왔거든요.
그럼에도 불구하고 메모리 ETF가 최근 높아진 가격의 부담을 못 이기고 하락하고 있어요.
참고로 이제 키오시아 실적만 살짝 말씀드리면 키오시아가 매출액이 전 분기 대비 84% 증가했고 순이익이 전 분기 대비 364% 증가했습니다.
그러니까 지금 키오시아가 실적이 미쳐 날뛰고 있다 이렇게 볼 수가 있겠어요.
그러니까 전 분기 대비 300% 이상의 이익 성장을 하고 있는 그런 미친 상황이고요.
가이던스 역시 미쳤는데.
가이던스도 전 분기 대비 100%씩은 영업이익이 성장할 거다 이런 얘기를 하고 있습니다.
그리고 전년 동기 대비해서는 영업이익이 2700% 상승하고 순이익이 4600% 상승할 거다.
이런 정말 뭐랄까 이게 정말 말이 되는 숫자인가 그런 모습을 키오시아가 보여주고 있다.
상대적으로 랜드 업계에서도 3전 하이닉스가 오히려 좀 잘 나가고 있지.
키오시아는 그 다음 티어거든요.
근데 이렇게 키오시아도 잘 나간다라는 거 매우 좀 흥미로운 부분이고 업황이 어떻게 보면 좋다라는 증거일 수도 있겠습니다.
그래서 랜드의 업황이 좋다라는 얘기로도 시장에서 받아들여질 수 있기 때문에 샌디스크가 디램 ETF는 힘든 시간을 보내고 있지만 랜드만을 만드는 샌디스크는 그래도 좀 잘 버티는 중이다.
그리고 또 샌디스크랑 키오시아는 약간 영혼의 단짝 같죠.
공장을 공유해요.
이 두 회사가 그래서 어느 정도 좀 같이 갈 수밖에 없는 그런 부분들이 있는데.
이제 그런 샌디스크가 키오시아가.
키오시아가.
키오시아가 잘 나왔던 걸로 보면서 샌디스크도 잘 좋겠구나 이런 생각을 시장에서 했던 것 같고요.
또 이거는 사실 어젠가 그젠가 나온 뉴스이긴 한데 그래도 좀 제가 언급을 해야 될 것 같아서 알파벳이 엔화 채권을 발행을 했습니다.
그래서 한국 돈으로 한 50조 60조 원에 달하는 엄청나게 큰 돈을 빌렸어요.
외국 기업 사상 최대로 엔화 채권을 발행했다라고 합니다.
알파벳이 돈을 계속 빌리고 있고 알파벳이 돈을 왜 계속 빌리냐.
당연한 얘기죠.
AI에다 돈 쓸려고 또.
AI에다 돈 쓸려고 또 60조 이렇게 빌린 겁니다.
그런데 아시겠지만 2026년 연간 캐펙스 가이던스를 상향했거든요.
상향했으니까 영업 현금 흐름으로는 그걸 메꿀 수가 없으니까 돈 빌려서 그걸 메꾸겠다라는 겁니다.
그래서 알파벳의 회사채 규모가 커지고 있고 또 아시겠지만 일본이 금리가 낮다 보니까.
이제 엔화로 된 채권을 조달하면 갚아야 되는 그 금리가 저렴하다 보니까 엔화 채권을 빌린 거다라고 보시면 될 것 같습니다.
그리고 보시면 아시겠지만.
지난 15개월 사이에 알파벳이 정말 다양한 통화로 자금을 조달을 했어요.
아마 앞으로도 많은 빅테크들이 회사채를 발행하면서 자금을 조달해 나가지 않을까 이런 생각이 들고요.
다행히 어떻게 보면 시장의 반응이 이런 채권 조달에 대해서 발작하거나 이러지는 않기 때문에.
당분간은 이런 채권 발행으로 자금 조달을 하면서 AI 캐펙스를 조달을 하지 않을까 그런 생각이 저는 계속 듭니다.
그리고 정상회담 아까 제가 짧게만 말씀드렸는데 또 어떤 얘기들이 있었는지를 보면.
아무래도 가장 민감한 대만에 대한 이야기가 있었습니다.
트럼프는 어떤 얘기를 좀 했었냐면 시진핑이 대만 문제로 전쟁을 원하지는 않는다라고 말을 했고요.
그리고 어떤 일이 있었냐 시진핑이 만약에 중국과 대만의 분쟁이 발생할 경우에 미군을 파견할 것이냐라고 시진핑이 트럼프한테 물었더니 트럼프가 뭐라고 말했냐.
I don't talk about 나는 말 안 할 거다라는 거죠.
나는 미국이 대만을 지킬지 말 안 할 거다.
답변을 거부했다라고 합니다.
뭐랄까 이런 거 봤을 때는 트럼프도 시진핑의 어떤 그 영민을 건드리고 싶어 하지 않는 모습 트럼프가 오히려 좀 깨갱하는 그런 느낌이 좀 들었고요.
다만 트럼프는 또 와서 이런 얘기를 했죠.
미국의 대만 정책에 대해서 변한 것이 없다라고 하면서 그 모호성 정책이라고 합니다.
되게 애매하게 그러니까 미국이 대놓고 야 내가 대만 지킬 거야.
중국 깝치지 마라고 하면 중국을 도발하는 거니까 그렇게는 안 하고.
약간 모호하게 하지만 대만을 포기하지는 않는 듯하지만 또 중국을 막지는 않는 듯한 뭔가 그런 좀 애매한 정책들을 계속 유지하고 있는 모습을 보였고요.
그 외에도 트럼프는 중국 회사들이 이란 석유를 갖고 오는 거에 대해서 제재를 할 수도 있지만 그런 제재를 해제할 가능성에 대해서 논의를 했다라고 합니다.
그러니까 계속 좀 뭐랄까 트럼프는 중국한테 뭘 좀 퍼준다라고 해야 되나.
이번 정상회담 하면서 좀 퍼주는 그런 모습 약한 모습을 계속 보이고 있다라고 보시면 될 것 같고요.
또 트럼프가 이제 이란과 관련된 이야기들도 했는데 우라늄 빅축물에 대해서는 좀 논의하지 않기로 이란과 얘기를 했다라고 합니다.
이런 것들은 그래도 좀 긍정적으로 봐야 되지 않나 뭐 이런 생각이 들고요.
또 이란 핵 프로그램에 대한 20년 전면 중단 정도는 수용하겠다라고 또 트럼프가 밝히기도 했어요.
그래서 트럼프가 조금씩 약한 모습을 보이는 게 제가 너무 긍정적일 수도 있지만 호르무즈 이 사태에 어느 정도 종결 가까워지고 있는 걸로 봐야 되는 거 아닌가 뭐 이런 생각을 하긴 하는데.
그래서 증시가 안 되니까.
어떻게 될 것이냐 여러분들도 궁금하고 저도 궁금한데 결국에는 파괴적인 실적과 이 물가 사이에서의 싸움이 되지 않을까 이런 생각이 자꾸 듭니다.
UBS에서는 어떤 코멘트를 좀 남겼냐면 케빈 워시는 이 정도의 공급 쇼크로 인한 물가에 대해서는 그냥 넘어갈 가능성이 높지 않을까 이런 코멘트를 남겼고요.
또 올 스프링에서는 어떤 코멘트를 남겼냐면 금리 인하 하긴 할 건데 그 시기가 좀 밀릴 것 같다.
그리고 여전히 유가 쇼크 연준에서 일시적으로 볼 수 있을 것 같다.
이런 생각을 하고 있습니다.
그래서 제가 보기에는 좀 간을 보는 듯한 시장 이게 만약에 2022년 같은 시장이었다면 이런 물가를 보면서 깜짝 놀라면서 막 주가가 폭락을 해야 될 텐데 그러기에는 생각보다 실적들이 좀 잘 나와 주잖아요.
오늘 뭐 키옥시아 실적도 그렇고 계속 여러 기업들의 실적들이 AI 관련된 회사들의 실적은 꽤나 괜찮게 나오면서 주가가 떨어질 때마다 저가 매수 물량도 같이 들어오는 얼마 전에도 CPI 나오면서 폭락했을 때 속쓸의 저가 물량.
오늘 뭐 키옥시아 실적도 그렇고 계속 여러 기업들의 실적들이 AI 관련된 회사들의 실적들이 저가 물량.
필라델피아 반도체 세배 ETF의 역대급 매수 물량이 들어오듯이 좀 가격이 떨어지면 이 실적이 지금 워낙 좋다 보니까 매수 물량도 돌아오면서 그 두 가지 힘이 계속 싸우는 지금 그런 형국이라고 봐야 될 것 같습니다.
매수 물량이 들어오듯이
좀 가격이 떨어지면
실적이 지금 워낙 좋다 보니까
매수 물량도 돌아오면서
그 두 가지 힘이 계속 싸우는
지금 그런 형국이라고 봐야 될 것 같습니다
그래서 본격적인 하락 추세다
얘기하기 좀 어려운 것 같고요
오히려 이럴 때일수록 좀 더 관망하고
지켜보면서 생각을 정해야 되지 않나
라는 생각을 합니다
주식이라는 게 언제는 분명했겠습니까
늘 모호한 것 같고요
이 모호한 시장 속에서
잘 생존하시길 기대하면서
저는 또 다음 영상으로 돌아오도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다